I have a story for you today of just
good old-fashioned extremist homophobia
and it's about West Virginia Republican
Eric Porterfield Eric porterfield says
that he would drown his children if they
turned out to be gay but you've got to
know how to understand the language that
he's using during this interview on wvv
a I will tell you that he wore the
requisite Magga hat during the interview
he called LGBT people a modern-day KKK
which is sort of weird since he seems
like a guy that would like the KKK but
he seems to be saying the KKK is bad
because LGBT people are like the KKK
anyway I'm gonna play the clip for you
but we're going to do audio only and I
apologized for that the reason is that
the videos from a local news station and
as I've mentioned before local news
stations are really litigious with
copyright claims even though I believe
we are using their clips as fair you
under fair use we are doing an analysis
of what the content is they immediately
slap us with copyright strikes and our
YouTube channel gets all messed up so
we're going to just play audio for you
you can find the video online if you
want it listen and then he's going to
use the code I would see if they can
swim for drowning and notice how quickly
the interviewer simply says ok and moves
on to the next thing I would like to see
her actually question the guy and say
are you saying you would drown your
children if they were gay she doesn't
but that's what he's saying ask you this
yes ma'am
you have a adorable daughter and a
precious son what would happen if a few
years from now when they're teens young
adults they came to you and said that
they think that they might be gay or
lesbian well I will address my daughter
first as I would take her for a pedicure
I take her to get her nails done and see
if she could swim if it was my son I
would probably take him hunting I would
take him fishing and I'd see if he could
swim what do you mean us you think it's
well I just want to make sure they could
swim that's just that that's it I mean
I'll take them out to do activities
okay um yeah so this guy's a piece of
work but before we get to that there was
an opportunity here for the interviewer
to go viral okay if the interviewer
responds directly with when you say see
if they can swim do you mean drown your
children because they're gay and that
would have been a that would have been
instantly viral as hero news reporter at
least among sensible people the right
would have called for her firing so
let's talk more about this guy last week
during a floor debate at the West
Virginia legislature there was a
discussion about a bill which would ban
the protection of LGBT people with
anti-discrimination laws Eric Porter
feel actually used the word [ __ ] during
the debate okay during the floor debate
about banning
anti-discrimination laws the position
that he is sort of assembling from his
different political points of view is
that abortions are bad but drowning your
kids because they're gay is apparently
not so bad in the completely deranged
world of Eric porterfield
this is why the left can't compromise
with some elements of the right people
like John McCain
you can compromise with you can find
common ground do we agree on foreign
policy do we agree on all social issues
of course we don't but he's a normal
person that you can actually compromise
with on some issues how do you
compromise with a guy like this pad he
shouldn't even be allowed near children
never mind being in a position to make
political decision decisions and this is
why I think that there is an element of
the right that the idea of
bipartisanship might make sense but you
cannot do anything with a person like
this yeah this guy needs to go he should
not be an elected official
whatever happened to loving the sinner
but hating the sin I don't know and
especially it's even crazier because
these were his actual kids right these
are people who we presumably knows and
loves and he was willing to throw them
in the water and see if they can swim if
he finds out that they're gay come on
yeah and oftentimes you will see that
the one thing that gets people on the
right to
consider they're completely hateful
views is when you give them a scenario
that says well hold on what if your
child or your sister or whatever and
with some conservatives as horrible as
it is once they imagine themselves
suffering from something they can
sometimes say you know what maybe I do
need to revisit my view and it's
depressing that that's what it takes but
with some of them it does take that and
at least that changes their perspective
with this guy it's about his kids and it
still didn't even work and this gets me
back to thinking about the importance of
local races and politics because this is
a guy in the West Virginia legislature
and I know that if you live in Boston or
New York or in the country in Wyoming
this guy's decisions don't impact you
but the rights understanding of the
importance of getting people that are
aligned with them in lower positions of
power all over the country has worked
really well and the left needs to be
building their farm team not that this
guy I mean listen Trump's president so
who can say but not that this guy is
ever going to be President but the
importance of politics at the local
level should not be forgotten and this
guy should be a reminder of that to all
of us today's program is sponsored in
part by spresso bucks who are offering
everybody in our audience a bunch of
really cool free stuff suppressor Vox is
a company based in New York City and
they are going to make your life a lot
easier and save you money when it comes
to keeping up with men's fashion because
when you sign up for spreadable you get
a totally new box sent to your door
every month with five or six hand-picked
accessories and pieces of clothing
you'll get things like really stylish
socks neckties high-end sunglasses
wallets watches bracelets high-quality
pens and hair combs the list goes on but
it's all really nice stuff must-haves
for any guy who's wanting to update his
wardrobe I got some really cool stuff in
my espresso box including a money clip
as well as a very nice pocket square and
some really good-looking socks all of
which are very very cool thus preserve
our subscription is just 25 bucks a
month but you definitely come out ahead
because every box every single month is
guaranteed
need to have items with a combined value
of over $100 so they make it easy to
keep your outfits fresh but you're also
getting a lot of bang for your buck and
it makes a really great gift for a guy
in your life everyone in our audience
can get one month totally free when you
click the link underneath this video and
use the promo code Pakman that's PA que
ma n